Interestingly, all the cloud
computing is a relatively new trend.
As a vision, it existed for
a very long time.
The oldest description,
by John McCarthy,
predates the technology by almost half
a century, and it appeared in 61.
He said the following.
If the computers of the kind I have
advocated become the computers of
the future, then computing may some
day be organized as a public utility,
just as the telephone
system is a public utility.
The computer utility could become
the basis of a new and important future.
If you look at this statement,
it describes a vision where computing
is a utility just like other utilities.
If we need more electricity,
we just turn the switch on.
We don't worry about where
the electricity actually comes from.
Based on this vision, cloud computing
should turn the IP resource
into a fungible utility, where we
don't care about what type of CPUs or
disk I'll ultimately use or
where they are.
Virtualization technology is one
enabling the process, certainly.
Unfortunately there's still
limitations before this vision of
just seamless computing
utility can be realized.
For instance, even with virtualization
there's still some hardware dependencies
that simply cannot be masked.
So if software expects a certain type
of hardware plot form to execute then
we cannot just have it run
on another type of resource.
Then there is the API lock-in where if
we're using a particular cloud provider
then we're expected to
continue using those API's.
There isn't a uniform standard
across cloud providers.
And then, unlike with some of these
other utilities, where we're simply
bringing this resource, the electricity
in, in the case of cloud computing
we're putting data, potentially core
business services out in the cloud.
So some of the privacy and security
concerns become much more important.
Clearly latency's is an issue given that
there is an actual geographic distance
related to our axis to our.